- It's gotten to the
point where it tastes like
I'm just eating spoonfuls of sugar.
(upbeat keyboard music)
Today we're having over a
hundred different Kit Kats.
I'm gonna try 'em all
and tell you which one
is definitively the
best flavor of Kit Kat.
Last time I had too much
food, I tried every item
on the McDonald's menu.
That was very difficult.
Oh, god.
Wow, oh, gosh, this is a lot of candy.
Oh, wow, this guy's (bleep) pumped.
This one smells bonkers.
Mmm, wow, it really tastes like tangerine.
This one smells like dark chocolate.
Tastes like chocolate.
Alright, this is a vampire.
It says, "hand talk".
Why is that the only English they gave me?
I don't know what flavor this is.
Coconut? Vanilla?
(light guitar music)
Remember when you're 12
and you go the dentist
and they give you strawberry fluoride?
It's strawberry fluoride Kit Kat.
I'm goin' for one of these single ones.
These are Kit Kat fancy.
This looks like a tiny energy bar.
Mmm.
Tastes like eating a plant.
Alright, let's try strawberry.
Oh, it smells like Pocky.
Wow, Kit Kat is...
It's Pocky.
(ascending boinging)
Hock-o, ho-kay-do melon.
Tastes like watermelon Bubblicious.
Cookies and cream.
Kind of tastes caramel-y.
A little coffee-ee.
It tastes like a treat you'd
get at a Christmas open house
at a furniture store.
It looks to be two pieces of toasted bread
with beans in the middle.
How many have I had?
(speed talking)
16 or 17?
That's not very many.
This one's boring.
Oh, this one's called amaze-egg.
Ama-zegg, a-mez-ak-ee.
Oh, wow, it smells
immediately like alcohol.
It kinda burns like alcohol burns.
Oh, god! (laughs)
Oh, it's sour!
Oh, whoa!
Another white chocolate one, my god.
What, (laughs) is that?
Lemon?
Oh, god, it's white chocolate again.
Grape.
It's purple, as we all expected.
Like, it's not bad.
Cognac and grapes.
It tastes like Jewish wine.
So this is a nice bright green,
maybe a lime, maybe a mint?
Is it wasabi?
I actually kinda like this.
Shinshu apple?
Smells like green Jolly Ranchers.
Let's try this strawberry maple.
Strawberry maple sounds
like what happens when
a cute girl from the
south marries a Canadian.
No maple in that strawberry maple.
No strawberry.
Okay, you gotta up your game.
This is a different packaged sake one,
so I'm assuming it's gonna be different.
That one really tastes like sake.
You know how, like, you're not in control,
like your brain is doing stuff
without your conscious brain knowing it?
I keep, like, going to
put this in my mouth,
and my hand keeps stopping
short of my mouth. (laughs)
(crunching)
This feels nice, it's cold.
♪ Sa-ku-ra. ♪
♪ Cherry blossoms everywhere. ♪
Mmm. (smacking)
That was the one.
This is inspired by chock-la-tor-y.
Sounds like a chocolate purgatory.
Yep, tastes like butter.
♪ Sa-ku-ra. ♪
God, it's white chocolate.
Sounds like a chocolate purgatory.
♪ Cherry blossoms... ♪
(belches)
Oh, god.
I'll eat one bar.
One bar.
I don't know if I can keep going anymore.
Well, this is fun.
I didn't eat 'em all but I think I tasted
all the different flavors
and, in terms of an answer,
this matcha, the sakura
matcha, is the best one.
All right, we'll see you next time
on Keith ruins his stomach.
(ominous chord)
- So, as you just saw,
Keith didn't actually
finish the challenge.
So, I thought that I'll
surprise him with more Kit Kats
that he has to finish
by the end of the day.
(upbeat clarinet music)
- Well, hey.
Right, yup.
I didn't.
Oh, I just have to
finish what I didn't eat,
so how many is that?
See ya later.
Thanks.
Whoa, shit, look at this!
Oh, my god!
(crunching)
That one's good.
(smacking)
Oh...
Ooh, it's pink.
Really delicate and lovely.
Ugh.
Nice little pile.
Raspberry's in the wafer.
(groaning)
I hope you enjoy the video.
(upbeat instrumental music)